[Music]
it's your resident beauty nerd here
Michelle of flab muffin B desires and
today we're talking about anecdotal
evidence it sounds sort of abstract but
it's really important to understand
because that sort of explains why my
channel exists why science is important
when it comes to figuring out what
actually works for beauty products and
for other things in life as well like
medical treatments and nutrition and
supplements if you like videos about the
science behind beauty products make sure
you click the thumbs up subscribe to my
channel and click the notification bell
so you don't miss any videos anecdotal
evidence is when someone says that
something worked for them or someone
they know basically it's a one-off
example of something working or not
working for example I use this cream the
next day a pimple disappeared and so
this cream must work for treating
pimples or I took some multivitamins
then my [ __ ] got better so that means
multivitamins fix my cold or my
grandma's smoked continuously and died
at 92
so cigarettes aren't that bad for your
health we see anecdotal evidence
everywhere in Beauty testimonials and
reviews are all forms of anecdotal
evidence and anecdotal evidence isn't
just limited to regular consumers expert
opinions experience and case reports are
often forms of anecdotal evidence as
well medical professionals scientists
and beauty professionals all use and
misuse anecdotal evidence it's simply
part of being human all human beings
have evolved to naturally be subjective
and prone to biases distortions now
thinking that stopped us from being
purely objective and rational machines
these biases actually helped us survive
through the ages but unfortunately they
don't help us as much in the modern
world
[Music]
anecdotal evidence can be very useful in
some situations if you're going for a
beauty treatment you probably want an
experienced therapist rather than a
brand-new one but the problem with
anecdotal evidence is while it sometimes
really useful it isn't reliable and we
as humans have a bias to give it far
more weight than it deserves anecdotes
aren't good enough evidence for saying a
particular treatment led to a particular
outcome
and if anecdotal evidence disagrees with
good scientific studies and there's no
plausible explanation for how a
particular treatment might work we
should go with what the science says
anecdotal evidence can be incredibly
convincing it's a lot easier to believe
someone's heartfelt story than it is to
try to understand faceless complicated
and often scarily technical scientific
data even if there are many someone's
behind that data this is part of the
reason why documentaries are so
compelling and why a lot of people who
are pushing pseudoscience choose to use
documentaries to present their case and
our love of personal stories was great
for human survival if you avoided all
red berries because one person died from
eating them you end up living a lot
longer and passing on your genes even if
not all red berries are dangerous this
quick mental shortcut allowed us to stay
alive most of the time but unfortunately
these quick mental shortcuts these
cognitive biases that inform our gut
feelings they also give us a distorted
view of reality we live in a much more
complex world now and we need and have
much better tools to work out what's
going on then anecdotal evidence I know
it can feel really unnatural to ignore
your gut feelings but a lot of the time
these gut feelings and instincts evolved
to help us survive under very
circumstances than our modern world
being aware of these sorts of biases
that we have towards anecdotal evidence
means we can compensate for it this
makes us more aware of what actually
works and makes us much less vulnerable
to being manipulated by dodgy marketing
being aware of these are rationalities
that we all naturally have means we can
make better decisions about what to do
and what to buy so let's go through some
of the problems with anecdotal evidence
I'll be focusing on the ones that are
more relevant to beauty products some of
these issues have fancy tech
name so I'll put the names of them on
the screen as I'm explaining them one of
the biggest problems with anecdotal
evidence is that things get better on
their own a lot of the time back to the
pimple example as most of us have
probably experienced pimples tend to get
better on their own in about a week and
if you're anything like me you probably
won't bother doing anything about it
until about three days in when it's at
its rapists so there I am putting cream
on a single pimple and it clears up
about three days later to me it looks
like it works but maybe in a different
time line I use the light pen instead
and the pimple cleared up so it looks
like the light pen worked or in a third
time line I used a pimple patch and that
looked like it worked but all along if I
just left it alone it would have cleared
up as well and so really none of them
worked or maybe say I use the pimple
cream and my pimple went away faster
than normal and so it looked like it
worked but that week I also used a new
cleanser and apply some exfoliant and
went on a health kick and ate a whole
bunch of vegetables any of these could
have helped the pimple go away faster
but I only linked the pimple cream to
the pimple in my mind because that's
what I expected to work even worse a lot
of the time we forget about
longer-lasting treatments and we only
remember the last thing we used I might
have even started on the contraceptive
pill which takes a while to start
working to reduce pimples then I use the
pimple cream and then the hormones
kicked in and made the pimple go away
faster than normal but I think it's just
the cream these are all examples of how
one thing happening doesn't mean that it
caused the next thing just because I
used the pimple cream and the pimple
went away doesn't mean that the pimple
cream worked another issue is that
humans just aren't great at observing
things I'm sure you've all had the
experience where you and a friend can't
agree on something really mundane like
what color shirt someone was wearing at
a party or whether McDonald's
cheeseburgers are actually getting
smaller one researcher actually
developed a method that could make 1/3
of people believe that a made-up event
happened in their childhood and not only
did they believe it they would even tack
on extra details when they talked about
this event to someone else we're really
good at filling gaps in our memory with
random stuff and tricking ourselves into
believing things with a pimple unless
you've been really carefully measuring
it every day you can easily trick
yourself into thinking it's getting
bigger or smaller
it's growing lighter or redder if you
spent a lot of money on the pimple cream
and you really want it to work you might
even subconsciously trick yourself into
believing that you can see a change
forgetting all the times that you used
it and it didn't work this is an example
of confirmation bias or wishful thinking
and this effect can be bigger for more
expensive products it's called post
purchase rationalization where you don't
want to believe that you've wasted your
money on something that didn't work as
I've talked about in my ebook the lab
muffin guy two basic skincare there are
a few ways that you can try to make your
observations as objective as possible so
things like photos and skin diaries but
while these can help you trick yourself
less it still isn't foolproof so ideally
how could we tell if a pimple cream
really helps clear up pimples what we
have to do is set up a fair test so we
can specifically compare the pimple
cream with no cream at all we'd make
sure that everything else stayed the
same for example if you had two
identical pimples on either side of your
face then everything you ate should
affect both pimples equally you could
also make sure that you used every other
skincare product equally on both sides
of your face or stopped every other
product altogether this is called
controlling the variables if the pimple
cream worked we'd also want to make sure
it wasn't a one-off fluke where the
lighting made the pimple look smaller
or the pimple was a less severe pimple
than normal all the persons crash cone
pimple in their sleep but not the other
instead of just trying the pimple cream
on one pimple we could try the pimple
cream on lots and lots of pimples and
then get rid of the one-off fluke
results if we wanted to test whether a
specific ingredient worked for pimples
we could even make two creams one with
the ingredient and one without and test
the two creams against each other to
make sure the people recording the
results aren't biased we could label the
creams a and B and not tell them which
one was which and that's pretty much
what science does it sets up fair tests
that get rid of as much human
subjectivity and bias as possible
[Music]
so hopefully that gives you a better
idea of why scientific evidence is
better than anecdotal evidence if
science says one thing but anecdotes say
another you should go with what the
science says but one of the big issues
with skincare is that there's just not
that many high-quality scientific
studies around the best ones are for
prescription products or for more
serious skin conditions like rosacea a
lot of studies aren't fair tests or they
test only one specific product that's
too different from a product you're
using to draw any convincing comparisons
or maybe they just didn't test enough
people to say much one way or another so
if we don't have a lot of science to
guide us that's where personal
experience and reviews become much more
valuable because it's the best we have
but given how subjective and prone to
biases this anecdotal evidence is there
are a few things we should keep in mind
so that we aren't mislead reviews can be
a fantastic resource for finding
products that work well for you but make
sure you don't believe every review you
read as well as all of the problems with
anecdotal evidence that I mentioned
before there are a few extra things to
keep in mind with reviews many companies
post fake reviews of their products they
might pay someone to turn up tons of
positive reviews and post them online
under fake profiles even if they aren't
fake reviews can also be incentivized if
a company gives up free samples or pay
someone to review their products this
conflict of interest can mean that the
review is more favorable than it might
otherwise be but at the same time just
because someone was paid or is a free
product it doesn't mean that that's the
only reason why a review is positive and
even if someone is reviewing a product
that they bought themselves it doesn't
mean that it will be completely
objective there are issues I mentioned
before like confirmation bias where
someone sees a change because they're
expecting a change and post purchase
rationalization especially if it's an
expensive product there are also issues
if you're looking at multiple reviews
you might see a lot of very good reviews
or very bad reviews and that's because
humans are kind of lazy
unless something works really well or
really badly we're not likely to go to
the trouble of writing a review we can't
get a
good idea of how likely it is we'll get
a good result how representative these
reviews are if we see ten rave reviews
we can't easily tell if it's a niche
product we're only ten people tried it
and they all loved it or a mediocre but
popular product where thousands of
people tried it but it only worked well
for ten people very few people update
their reviews so we don't know if the
product continued to work well for
someone or if they change their mind
after trying it for longer humans are
also better and remembering recent
things more clearly products with
immediate results will probably get more
positive reviews than a product that
works better but takes a longer time to
start working if you've ever read
skincare reviews you'll know that
different people can have very different
experiences with the same product in
scientific studies the people they tried
a product on I usually describe very
specifically you can work out how close
you are to the source of people they
tried the product on but in reviews you
usually know very little about the
reviewer so where does this leave us as
Beauty consumers this is where I talk
about what I personally think is a
sensible approach you might disagree and
that is perfectly valid your best bet
for products that will work for you are
those that have enough scientific
evidence to back up its effectiveness
but also have a large number of
reasonably objective positive reviews
from people in a similar situation as
you if there isn't any scientific
evidence for that exact product then you
want there to be some evidence for its
active ingredients if you don't have
that then you want a plausible mechanism
a scientifically sound explanation for
why you could possibly work and no
compelling scientific reason that it
wouldn't work if anecdotal evidence
disagrees with the scientific evidence
then you should go with what the
scientific evidence says the higher the
risk both health-wise and in terms of
budget the stronger that scientific
evidence should be anecdotal evidence is
still useful in helping us decide which
products to try as long as we keep in
mind the limitations and don't treat it
as proof of something working I hope you
enjoyed this video it's a little bit
different it's more about why we care
about science rather than the science
behind a particular product so please
let me know what you think in the
comments if you like videos on the
science behind beauty products
the thumbs up and you can subscribe to
my channel you can also find me on my
blog lab muffin comm and on instagram
under lab muffin beauty science